cowabunga everybody Ninja Turtles are in
the theaters right now
they won the weekend box office they've
already greenlit a sequel but we believe
that they can do better and we've
brought in our resident fixer mr. Nick
Mundy to lay it out for us Nick this is
my segment but I guess my fearless
leader said I need to learn about
teamwork and you're a team here's the
thing this is a subject that we are all
passionate about so everyone wanted to
be here to support unit all right fine
fine
so Ninja Turtles you guys won the box
office Yuri got greenlit for a sequel
but that doesn't mean you can rest on
your laurels
we're here to tell you how to fix Ninja
Turtles - BAM a la bomba rule one more
Turtles this isn't the bacon Fox movie
we don't we don't care about Megan Fox
we care about the Turtles and that's the
one thing you guys got right they were
fun that elevator scene was probably the
best scene in the movie I will totally
admit that I was impressed they did that
because when I first saw those turtles
yeah I was like holy [ __ ] I don't want
to see this movie
that looks ridiculous I have to totally
give them credit for making me fall and
actually enjoy those turtles yeah
because when we just saw the pictures
before the movie they look like write it
out mugs drop I came in expecting to
item I think the to your point though
they really took too much from the
Transformers franchise or I feel like
the reason it did succeed over Trent I
started gonna pitch this up like yeah I
get can we can we just agree - can we
it's really hard to have a serious
discussion wearing these no let's flip
my oh my oh yeah can we take these masks
off cuz they're driving me damn crazy
okay I was gonna say I think they took
too much from the Transformers like
scripting rule of filmmaking where it's
like Sam's parents all these humans that
ya overused and those transform movies
but where turtles actually could succeed
is the turtles have character the
turtles are fun you want to watch them
yes my other pull but my point is we've
seen where you going front legs pull all
the way down
but my point is I just think like yes
they got the turtles right they match
their archetype that they've had but
like for the sequel
let's see some growth because they've
been like what five turtle movies three
TV shows they're never changing
let's see them grow boom Nick what do
you got next
forget the origin story okay just
completely forget it forever okay we
will completely forget that splinter
taught them ninjutsu from a book we're
going to forget that April's dad and
Eric Sachs created the turtles and we're
also going to forget that
April rescued them from a fire instead
of saving their dad who either got shot
by an arson fire forehead of all she
jumps the minister comes of the sewer
let's just agree the frogs got the
origin out you had to jump it over we
never talked about it
damage has been done never discussed we
don't have to talk about it don't try to
wreck on it don't try to fix it's dust
it's dumped on it's like how we forgot
about the Man of Steel episode we
completely forgot it you can move on and
just focus on on other things on greater
things okay we got that Nick give us
another one how about we get a real
shredder in the next Ninja Turtles movie
what tonight I dine on turtle soup
I don't know was Eric sacks supposed to
be shredder it looked like that's the
way it was going so apparently there
were these reshoots right Dan
well I there's I mean there's not been
any confirmation but our good friend
Andre the black nerd brought up a great
point in his review of the movie which
was that William Fichtner was supposed
to have played the shredder he said I am
sweet we've done interviewed I've seen
interviews with him he said he was
playing shredder I am the sheriff and if
you go back and look at it it's like you
only see the real shredder once I think
or maybe yes and it's in like a black
yard at a room shadowy there's no other
characters on the scene but that leaves
us with no shredder we had this blank
vaguely Asian guy who does a nominal
reference to the cartoon with serious he
knives on each arm
but we never see him again you know what
with all that said let's put Fichtner in
the shredder costume and then
he could be a badass shredder yeah cuz
he's a great actor you you're just
wasting him when he's just like you know
staring and like collecting his paycheck
well he still got a pharmaceutical
company to run yeah I just love that
they actually were so worried because
there was all this backlash of shredders
in that Asian what are we gonna do flame
finger a shredder was the least of this
movies yeah yeah it was like the
executives like hey guys
the Internet's really a thing on a like
a lot of our choices what's the easiest
thing to do
the shredder armors not supposed to be
scary now shredders supposed to be yes
for the second one William Fichtner is
the shredder as Batman he's in the
shadows he's scheming he's going to take
revenge he's gonna take them down
shredder needs his own boss and it needs
to be cranked which takes us to our next
rule embrace the Ninja Turtle universe
so like Amy was saying shredder probably
needs a boss
hey that mutagen is alien like that's
fine no one cares about that from what
alien planet or what dimension right
let's bring Krang into the movies
there's been five movies why haven't we
seen Krang let's explore the world Ninja
Turtles does have a rich history that
you can take from and Krang is the start
of things like the Emperor and shredders
Darth Vader you know it's just creepy
awesome dynamic with even the villains
that that we could be spending time on
instead of Will Arnett trying to get an
April O'Neil's pan hello you could also
bring you could also bring Baxter
Stockman let's talk about that who which
characters do you each want to see cuz I
think I even know he's been there again
I still want to see Casey Jones again
it'd be great to see some bebop and
rocksteady there hey guys you know who
would make the break you need them for
sure you know who would make a great
Casey Jones and he's worked with Michael
Bay before Chris Meloni okay I was gonna
say the rock cuz oh god how great would
it be he's a legitimate threat he's
bigger than the turtles right for Casey
Joe hi mr. Johnson I love you but you're
not right for kick Casey Joe why cuz
he's a badass who can throw weapons up
you're just trying to get your friend to
work but I think this speaks to a bigger
point as far as all the turtles movies
go which is that it seems like the
people are making these movies are
afraid to open it up because they think
it's too weird or they think it's
everyone ready
answer Ninja Turtles they're inherently
weird why not go for that and the fact
that the most weird out there
crazy batch insane movie is yeah that
has come out that I can remember it's
gonna probably be the number movie this
summer which gardens the galaxy and it
proves that it doesn't matter who you
characters are it doesn't matter where
it takes place if you write a good movie
it can tell a good story if you have
compelling characters people are gonna
go see it and I feel like the Ninja
Turtles like a Dimension X in a big
talking brain that's too weird make him
a badass villain I would I would be
there if a stuck had shown up at the end
in Ninja Turtles fans would have lost
their [ __ ] I'm tellin they ended the
movie above Times Square with the
shredder dangling a vial of ooze it
would have been so easy for him to drop
it and it falls on top of a pet store
right is a rhino and a warthog duck and
a rabbit and they all get coming the
engine they don't have to grow it's just
a teaser and they could have set up a
whole universe right I would have been
so much more exciting Oh with her
trailer carrying zoo animals yes um oh
that would have been circus yeah yeah
how about some neutrinos no go to hell
do you hear this Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle writers and directors please we
are excited about these give the fans
what they want I feel like this is the
first time Nick tell me if I'm wrong it
seems like a lot of times we do this
when we have would we do these how-to
fixes it's like it's it's almost like
we're we're shouting into the void
because we know there's no chance that
these things are gonna get fixed but I
feel like we can do it yes perfect way
to gather screen jockeys must we do
these how to fix is usually when the
movies already in the can that's it
but now we we might a leave time we met
the writers we should say that and they
seem like very smart nice guys I don't
mean to keep saying it's your fault who
knows whose fault it really was but I do
feel like now if you're back and I hear
their producers of this franchise
there's a rich Universal you need to
educate yourself on yeah and that the
fans are passionate about it doesn't
have to always please the hardcore fans
there's a younger audience that still
wants to see I get it but you can please
both Avengers is the perfect example of
where you can please them both by having
the Easter eggs and having everything
there and still being a great movie what
we're doing right now it comes out of
like love and excitement that like
there's a foundation of awesome turtles
they
a world that would that could make a
really fun sequel that we would be
excited to see and we're not this the
other thing is like people are gonna
watch this video but to
thirty-three-year-old butthurt fanboys
just bitching about the turtles that's
not it at all
like the turtles were I haven't watched
Ninja Turtles in 20 years like I'm not
connected it's just like it would be
cool to see those characters cuz they're
fun characters they don't have to be
just like they were when I was a kid
yeah but it would be fun to see a movie
with those characters well and I think
that's the thing people get wrong about
this whole segment is we want I don't
want movies to be bad I don't want to be
doing this segment right I'd rather be
doing
hey this movie is great let me yell
about it we want all the movies to be
good we want them to be great fans and
then but this one yeah if we do like a
couple of things it could be great and
that's what we want the first one
happened okay we move on with our lives
but let's make a kick-ass second one all
right guys we've laid out how to make
the next movie awesome now can we just
reassemble put our masks back on give
everybody a big Cowabunga dude right on
the count of three all right hang on one
two three Calabar I thought it was just
half of us good dude peppers didn't well
that was a good time how would you go
about fixing the next Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles movie leave us an answer
in the comment section below
we want to know this episode it's
brought to you by Best Buy where you can
experience the best in ultra HD TVs and
guess what screen junkies is giving away
an ultimate Ultra HD TV click the
Sweepstakes link in the description
below and enter for a chance to win
thanks again for watching the show on
how Rudnik hit me up on twitter bye bye
the rest of this thing is all
schwarzenegger number 2 terminator
against number 10
mando J OH